here to discuss the impact of the war on
european security and the economy is
estonia's prime minister kahakalis hello
to you thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning um you've seen
obviously the developing um situation in
ukraine this morning and the games the
war games that are going play taking
place in moscow
give me your overview of the situation
there at the moment
well this war has been going on for six
months already and and of course russia
is
is threatening more is he's more
aggressive than ever
because they are clearly not winning
this war as they expected to be a very
short
short
period of time when they achieve their
goals
what is important
here is that we keep on isolating russia
and we keep on
pushing them so that they would go back
to its borders and and withdraw the
aggression we have to support ukraine
every way we can
so that they can win this war because if
aggression pays off uh somewhere it's
serves as an invitation to use it
elsewhere
what happens do you think what happened
do you think six months ago what
convinced putin
that he should take this opportunistic
approach did he feel
that it was the situation that we saw
unfolding in afghanistan and the
withdrawal of troops there or did he
perhaps look at the um the breakup of
the european union not only with what
the uk was doing but also italy looking
at potentially leaving the eu as well
what do you think was in his mind
uh well uh of course uh it has been a
long plan i mean they haven't been
very secretive about their imperialistic
dreams when the soviet union collapsed
it's imperialistic
ambition never did
and and putin has been very clear about
this all along what has happened is that
when
russia attacked georgia
crimea donbass then nothing happened
to them i mean they were not punished
for the aggression so the message they
got was that this pays off because
eventually they have more territories
and every time with every uh next step
they have been bolder and of course all
the political uh situation uh government
changing in in germany uh also
the
energy crisis that was building up and
actually was uh influenced by the deeds
of russia not giving enough gas to
europe uh all these things are uh making
a perfect storm so that they would take
and and did take another step but right
now it's very important that we do
everything that this aggression does not
pay off and and they are punished for
the war crimes and aggression crimes
committed
i see that the russian defense minister
has been speaking this morning looking
at it via the reuters news agency saying
that uh the slowdown in pace in the
offensive in ukraine is uh deliberate so
that there will be fewer civilian
casualties do you think it is
if you look at their um their way of
operating then they have been attacking
civilian
civilians uh it is a war crime according
to international law uh when you target
civilians what we saw in mariupol was
complete uh destruction of the whole
city and especially forming hospitals
bombing places where there were marks
that they here are the children
but
so so
we shouldn't
we shouldn't listen to what they are
saying it's a information operation but
we should look at what they're doing and
what we see happening in ukraine is
completely uh vice versa they are
attacking civilians
britain sent an extra thousand troops
into estonia last month i think that's
brought that up to three 000
in total we know that the armed forces
minister james heapey on the programme
earlier on this morning has just
returned from estonia
what more do you need from the uk for
your people to feel safe safe against
the aggressor just across the border
first of all we are very grateful for
britain to
be our framework country so we have had
very good cooperation uh with great
britain and and the troops here present
working together with our own defense
forces have been a very good deterrent
for for russia as well that attacking us
would also mean attacking uk or france
or the other countries who are present
here
therefore we are very grateful
from
the madrid summit this summer we got
very strong decisions so that we are
building up a division-sized
headquarters here in estonia and and and
also uh britain is uh contributing to to
helping us do that and and allocating uh
some troops that are actually stationed
in uk but are ready to come to our aid
if necessary and this is all needed so
that it would never be
necessary in in reality that it would
act as a deterrent
a quick thought if i may ask you before
we let you go you called on the eu to
stop issuing tourist visas to russians
and we've heard from the eu's foreign
policy chief he's rejected
that call
do you think they are potentially being
blind to any danger that estonia might
face
um
the visa ban that we were calling for is
because we have a sanction put in place
so that there is no air travel between
europe and russia and and
so the russian tourists are traveling
via the land borders and only finland
estonia and latvia have land borders
with uh
with the russia so we are bearing the
burden really and the problem is that we
don't uh we are not able to check all
the tourists that come and we see that
they pose a security threat and i think
also that the traveling uh or being a
tourist traveling to europe is not the
human right it's a privilege and while
your country is waging a war
on ukraine the citizens of that country
are also responsible for their country's
deeds and therefore the visa ban could
have an effect so that this war would
end because only 10 percent of russian
citizens actually travel abroad and they
are from moscow and saint petersburg so
they these people also have influence on
kremlin's decisions so if they are uh
feeling this on on on their skin if i if
i may say so then they would put the
pressure also on kremlin uh prime
minister of estonia thank you very much
indeed for joining us